You are listening to radio lab radio from W.
N y. S. E. N. N. P. R.
So you're going to identify the Washington place cause I can't remember. Yeah,
yeah. Okay. Three, two, one. Ready?
I am ready but we should tell the audience that we're not gonna.
We're going to start this not in our usual studios spot. Not here.
Here where we're sitting down here.
Okay.
Just to explain, this is the Shakespeare theater in DC.
Recently Robert and I were there in front of about 800 folks just trying out
some material for the show.
We're getting with this story which comes from Plato actually by way of
Aristophanes. It's a 2,400 year old story breaking news. In other words,
and it goes like this.
Once upon a time he says people were not born separate from each other.
They were born intertwined, kind of coupled with each other.
So they were boys attached to boys and they were girls attached to girls and of
course boys and girls together in a wonderfully intimate ball.
And back then we had eight limbs. They were four on top, four on the bottom.
And you didn't have to walk if he didn't want to. You could roll and roll.
We did. We rolled backwards and we rolled forwards achieving fantastic speeds.
That gave us a kind of courage.
And then the courage swelled to pride and the pride became arrogance.
And then we decided that we were greater than the gods and we tried to roll up
to heaven and take over and heaven and the gods alarms struck back.
And Zeus in his fury hurled down lightning bolts and struck everyone into,
into perfect halves. So all of a sudden,
couples who'd been warm and tight and wedged together,
we're now detached and alone and lost and desperate and losing the will to live.
And the God's seen what they'd done,
worried that humans might not survive or even multiply again.
And of course they needed humans to give sacrifices and pay attention to them.
So the gods decided on a few repairs.
Instead of heads facing backwards or out,
they would rotate our heads back to forward.
They pulled our skin taut and nodded it right here at the belly button.
Genitalia two were moved to the front. So if we wanted to, you know, we could,
and most important, they left us with a memory.
It was a longing for that original other half of ourselves,
the boy or the girl who used to make us whole.
And that longing is still so deep in all of us. Men for men, women for women,
men for women for each other,
that it has been the lot of humans ever since to travel the world looking for
our other half. And when says, Aristophanes, when one of us meets another,
we recognize each other right away. We just know this.
We're lost in an amazement of love and friendship and intimacy.
We won't get out of each other's sight even for a moment. These are people,
he says, who passed their whole
lives together. And yet if you asked them,
they could not explain what they desire of each other.
They just do.
Very nice. Can I get an amen?
[inaudible]
so here's the thing. That story got us started on a little journey.
Truly began just thinking about wholeness and oneness and has looking for each
other
in all varieties of ways. Mirrors and shapes, relationships.
Beauty, the birth of the universe, the nature of life.
All of these things either have a simple deep beauty or
not.
I'm Jad Abumrad I remember [inaudible] this is radio lab and today for this hour
we are
desperately seeking this symmetry. By the way.
That was Zoe Keating on cello.
We'll hear more from earth throughout the hour cause she's awesome.
Every Bobby K [inaudible] I'm still thinking about her stuff and he's okay.
And uh, do you ever wonder, uh,
what actually happens when two people click, when the haves kind of meat,
meaning what, you know, you're going through your day, maybe you're at a party,
you meet people and you're like, hey, how are you? How are you?
And they say something and they try and be interesting and you try and be
interesting back. But in the end you're like,
I don't need to remember that name. Right? Of course. Yeah.
Gone and then comes along somebody,
every hundred times the stars align, the world falls away.
Things narrow and you just click. I knew that,
but do you ever wonder what actually happens in that moment?
Like when you meet someone that you really get, I just,
I don't think that there's anything that really feels better than that.
That's Lauren Silbert. She's a neuroscientist at Princeton. She wonders,
she's been wondering for a while when I was, I don't know,
maybe eight and I used to study with my dad,
we would go over things and I remember like I didn't understand this one like
math problem and he was explaining it to me and all of a sudden and I got it and
I started to cry and he got really nervous cause I was crying.
Why are you crying? Cause I was so excited that I like finally got it.
That's my first memory of really like d excited about the intensity of
understanding.
So fast forward 20 years,
Lauren is at Princeton and in the basement of our building here.
Can you just tell me where we are?
We are in the FN rife facilities in Green Hall at Princeton University.
They've got this giant brain scan, get magnets, looks like an airplane engine.
We're like a donut here can go donut. And as you know with the scanner,
you can put people in it and have them do tasks. Think,
think a thought or things, sing a song or watch a movie. And uh,
then the researchers can see into their brain, you know,
without having to cut in there. And Lauren got it into her head.
Could I use this big donut to investigate the clicking question?
So is the question when things click, what clicks, what plagues?
And if we can know what clicks can we learn how to make it click more?
So one day last year Lauren got into the brain scanner,
I sort of like it in there and she told this story and you just tell me that
story. Well it's a 15 minute, come on. Okay.
So I told the story actually told you the whole thing without any sort of hersa
fully maybe for, well 25, 17 times something,
something under 30, under 30 times.
I'm going to tell it one more time for everybody else to play a lot.
So the story is about her prom.
So Lauren is in high school and this guy that she doesn't really like asked her
to go to the prom. It's pretty awkward. But she's like, oh, okay. You know,
didn't know what to say. Nope. Subsequent to being asked by the first guy,
she actually falls for real for a second guy,
guy number two we just liked each other click.
So now she has a situation cause she likes the second guy said yes to the first
guy and he still wants to be the day he wants to be. Oddly enough,
he still wants to go with them. So she ends up going with guy number one.
So we get to the problem and a guy number two,
her boyfriend shows up drunk,
very drunk and punches fly. It gets messy. So she drags guy number two,
her boyfriend out to the parking lot.
But on the way to the car he trips and falls directly on his face right onto his
face, right onto his face on the concrete and he starts bleeding profusely.
So she's like, Oh, give me your keys. I'm going to drive. I'll drive your cart.
And if she doesn't have a license but he can't drive. Right.
So she drives them both out of the parking lot.
A couple minutes later they come upon an accident in the, in the street. Yeah,
it's right there. Some cars had gone into a thing, so they're rolling up to it.
I get distracted and she crashes into the accident that had already happened.
And it's just that the police were already there and they're like, watch this.
So the officer walks up, sees her no license,
sees this dude who's all bloody and messy and was like, all right,
give me your registration. She thinks she's going to jail.
But here is where faith steps in as the officer is walking back to his car with
her registration, a wind, a lucky win. One of those kicks up,
blows the registration out of the officer's hands.
He can't find it and he has no choice but to let her go. So then I just left.
So that was the story that forms the basis. Okay.
That is the story that forms the basis as fresh. Okay,
so now let's rewind [inaudible]. So anyhow,
she told that story in the scanner.
All the while the scanner snap pictures of her brain moment to moment.
Then she got a bunch of other people put them in the scanner and had the scanner
snap pictures of their brain as they're listening to the story with me so far.
Yup. Next did she compared brains? Okay,
so here I can show you a,
Lauren showed us brain scans where she divided each brain into thousands of tiny
little squares. So we call voxels thousands, thousands. Yeah.
So then what we can do is we can take one voxel in one brain and directly
compare it to the same exact voxel in the other brain. Shut up.
Wow. And we do this across the entire brain,
and this is where things get interesting when people really got her story,
because she had run them through all these tests to see if they could remember
the different chapters, the word she used.
So she was checking to see how well they listened. Yeah.
She would have them kind of recall the story. Okay.
Some were really good at recalling others, not so much. Now,
the people that did well like really well,
she found it as they were listening to her story,
their brain would literally begin to mirror hers.
All the little voxels in their head would start to sync up with all the little
voxels in her head. So they are, so they are just listening like anyone listens.
They just hearing what you're saying. Again, I get that. No, no,
let me put it to you a different way. You're right. I mean,
right now you and I are voxels are mirroring each other. You know,
like we're both speaking English. Yeah. So we can assume,
say 20% at least I would go 2124 let's say 24 okay.
But let's say you bump it up to 30 [inaudible] maybe bump it up to 35 no,
let's get a little higher.
(404) 024-0840 nine trusted you a at a 50% level.
But let's say we get to 50%,
even 60 there's a certain point at which something happens where it's no longer
me just describing an experience to you.
It's you actually having the experience, you know? Ah, yeah.
Like you know that the difference between x explanation and experience is like
the Grand Canyon, right? Well, she's found a way to quantify the gap.
So when I'm sitting there listening to Meryl Streep, I'm all Meryl inside,
outside and all around. Yeah,
that's 100% Merrill [inaudible] that's a hundred percent male straight.
He is not listening to this. You were saying,
I'll give you an example of what I was just saying here. Let me show you.
So while I was in Lauren's office, she showed me a,
this particular slide of her results.
So on this side we have this comprehension rank and what that means.
Basically it was a graph and on one axis sheet she had how much they actually
understood the story and could recall it.
And on the other axis she had how much their brain sinked up with hers,
which is sort of like how much they experienced the story. What are these marks,
by the way? Are these people? Sorry about the wait, these little exes. Oh,
these are individual subjects. I see. So if you take out this one outlier,
actually she pointed to this one subject two is way on one side of the graph.
Did that person is just didn't get your story at all? No. This person actually,
that person did understand her story,
scored really nice on comprehension but just didn't
sync up with her brain at all.
Um,
this person I t well so this is a little interesting.
Yeah, I know this person. You know this person. I know this person.
Yeah. To that person.
I'm almost positive is her fiance was,
there were some fights in gesture for real.
I mean for real. I don't think he was actually paying attention.
Um, but this one up here, she pointed to another subject.
Oh way on the other side of the graph who is a super brain coupling master was a
girl in Undergrad who I had never met before. Um,
and her brain coupled with my brain was twice as much as everybody else.
I mean really just like I contacted her after cause I wanted to like have lunch
with her and just see if we're the same person or not.
[inaudible]
and you never got back to me. What I know isn't that really,
it was sort of the end of their semester and I think she might've been away in
the weeks after I spoke with Lauren.
We emailed a few times and I kept asking her. I was like,
so what about that girl? The one who knew everything? Yeah.
Like how do you explain the connection? Is it a connection? Let's go meet her.
C'Mon, c'mon, c'mon. He didn't want to. No, she did actually.
And we started referring to the girl in email as a
BD media, meaning what? Meaning?
Brain Double Bidi Bidi Bidi Bidi Bidi Bidi Bidi [inaudible] bring. Yeah.
Anyhow, eventually after two weeks of constant emailing and searching,
BD turns up and agrees to meet
the meeting.
Took place on a sunny Tuesday afternoon at Princeton and I missed it because I
was on the round train. When I finally get there, BD has come and gone.
So you never laid eyes on BD? I did not,
but I talked to Lauren right after she had,
it was weird really. We sat down on a bench and she gave me the good. Okay.
You seem a little shaken. Yeah, it was a strange experience.
First thing she tells me is what the mystery girl's name is. Her name. Lauren.
My name is la. She was Lauren. And you were Lauren? Yes,
we're both named Lauren. Wow.
I know. It's weird, but there's kind of some guns out there. I know, but still,
that's so weird. I've thought at this point I'm like,
I mean this is like an era stuff and he's whopper here folks. So I was thinking,
and that's what Lauren told me that she had been expecting too beforehand,
hating her to come in and just like
the me. And when she showed up was she, you know,
not at all. Yeah.
Earlier they admitted a coffee shop and since I missed the whole thing,
I was very lucky that more number one had recorded the meeting on her laptop.
Okay. So I want to know, did you, where did you grow up?
I grew up in Vancouver. C in Vancouver. Yeah. Lauren.
One's theory was that they would have a common background or common,
something that would explain the symmetry between them.
But what you hear is Lauren one looking for points of connection and yourself.
Well listen. Okay. Do you have problem in Canada?
Is that a stupid question? Uh, well we do. I actually couldn't go to mine.
You didn't go to your prom? Yeah. Okay. I wish I could.
Did you, um,
did you have like significant relationships in high school? No.
No, not at all. I went to an all girls school. You went to an all girls school?
Yeah. Did you do a unicorn? Yeah. Was it like happen in the end?
There was not one thing they had in common, uh, except their names and
Princeton. Do you thought that this was going to be, you know, something?
I Dunno. Is it, maybe your premise is wrong. What do you mean? Well, uh,
actually I each snuck up to Columbia University and I asked her neuroscientist
about this actually. When did you do that while you were in Princeton?
I was on the subway going up to see Joey hurt. [inaudible] nice to meet you.
Went behind my back. What happened is I said to her, look,
we have this pretty great paper, and she agreed. It was a wonderful paper.
I said, it shows these two women who has seemed to be in such lock step.
Wouldn't you suppose that the two of them, if they ever met,
would become friendly or have some connection? Yeah.
I've come to the same conclusion.
If yours and my heartbeats were exactly the same,
depends on the circumstances.
If it was a beautiful night at a sinking moon in Venice, maybe
if you have elaborated the story beyond my question,
say your heartbeat is about 62 beats per minute.
Say Mine was exactly 62 beats per minute.
Would you say that we were more in sync than if mine was 72 beats per minute
that you and I were more soulmates?
No, probably not. I'd want to, but I, I don't know if I, you see,
I would want to, don't you want to,
when you see synchrony between the individuals?
Well, yes,
but I'm saying that I think that the conclusion doesn't follow from the data.
Joy says it's equally possible that Lauren too is just an extraordinarily good
listener.
Hello? Hey. Hey. Can you hear me okay?
Yeah, I can hear you.
In fact, when I finally got Lauren to on the phone, uh,
she did tell me that she is one of those people that when she hears a story,
she just falls in
to the point where somebody can be like, well, what?
And I don't hear it because I'm so focused on the book. Yeah. Um,
how do I explain it? So have you ever done any, any sports?
Yah. Soccer a little bit. Yeah.
Do you ever find that sometimes when you're playing soccer,
you are so into the game or you just reacting or whatever that you kind of lose
track of yourself for a little bit?
Yeah. It's like a dream state almost.
Yeah. Like a dream state. I definitely have that happen when I'm doing sports,
but I also sometimes how that happened when I, and I read
even. So do you think that you and Lauren one will become friends?
Um, I
honestly probably,
no, no, no.
Um, I, I mean, we're just, it's just, I just don't,
I wouldn't just want it, but she's,
oh, but not you. Don't you want to hang out with or don't you get to know her?
No. Okay. Jay, thank you very much.
Why don't you just sit down just for a second.
We're going to play a little nobody, but this morning, come on.
I think we can just repair all the damage that was just occurred to your
sensitive psyche. Just listen and we'll be right back.